but neither can the Chinese
or that hacker in Estonia a generation from now.
And government support for technologies like Tor and Bitcoin
mean giving up control,
but it means that developers, translators, anybody with an Internet connection,
in countries like Cuba, Iran and China, can sell their skills, their products,
in the global marketplace,
but more importantly sell their ideas,
show us what's happening in their own countries.
And so it should be not fearful,
it should be inspiring to the same governments
that fought for civil rights, free speech and democracy
in the great wars of the last century,
that today, for the first time in human history,
we have a technical opportunity
to make billions of people safer around the world
that we've never had before in human history.
It should be inspiring.
(Applause)